avec plus de 55 % de votants cluny n'a
pas subi un taux d'abstention record
comme de nombreuses communes de saône et
loire
et pourtant cela n'a pas profité au
maire sortant henri beugnot qui achève
son premier mandat
on n'a peut-être pas ça peut être pas
assez montré peut-être pas assez fait
campagne parce que faire campagne quand
on est aux affaires
c'est toujours un petit peu plus dur que
quand on est quand on est libre et donc
on a corrigé effectivement le tir on a
géré la crise la crise du pot vide
il fallait la gérait bien la gérer ce
qu'on a fait bon et on faire ressortir
le bilan qui est un bilan dont on est
particulièrement fier grande gagnante de
ce premier tour la candidate de gauche
marie fauves et arrive en tête avec à
ses côtés l'ancien maire et actuel
président de la communauté de communes
jean luc delpech et pour elle ce
résultat sanctionne la politique du
maire sortant
je sais pas si c'est un désaveu mais en
tout cas je pense qu'il ya une volonté
de changement qui est assez manifeste au
niveau de dcl une histoire et c'est
d'ailleurs notre accroche de comptes de
campagne pour le deuxième tour voulaient
que ça change mais aussi la mandature a
été aussi un peu compliqué avec les
liens qui ont pu ne pas se ne pas se
louer avec la communauté de communes et
actions de la communauté de communes
or on sait que notre notre action ici à
cluny elle est très liée notamment sur
plein de compétences mais notamment sur
l'économie sur le social sur le tourisme
tout est lié aussi avec l'intelligence
avec la communauté de communes
mais la gauche est divisée arrivé en
troisième position avec seulement 40 et
une voix de moins que le maire actuel
paul gallant espère tirer son épingle du
jeu en donnant à cluny une résonance
touristique internationale le premier
enjeu ça va être le label unesco
on devrait certainement l'obtenir aux
alentours des années 2025 à peu près et
les statistiques démontrent que lorsque
l'on est dépositaire de ce label il y à
une augmentation des touristes de
l'ordre de 30 à 40 %
donc cela doit nous faire réfléchir sur
l'accueil de ce flux de touristes au
niveau de l'hôtellerie au niveau de la
restauration niveau des stationnements
mais à cluny les deux camps sont divisés
arrivé en dernière position le centre
droit jacques lors on estime lui aussi
que le maire actuel n'a pas su séduire
les électeurs
pour moi c'est un désaveu mais ans je
l'avais rencontré déjà en 2008 en 2018
pour lui dire que j'allais monter un
groupe et en lui donnant mais les
raisons de ce manque de proximité parce
que nous c'est quelque chose qu'on
défend absolument au niveau de l'équipe
la sérénité et la proximité qu'on a
perdu depuis dix ans sur notre ville
reste maintenant à savoir si les
quelques 1500 votants qui ne se sont pas
déplacés au premier tour se rendront aux
urnes le 28 juin prochain